If you don't take any special steps,
most new objects that you create will delegate to the Object prototype, but
some of the special objects that you can make in JavaScript have
extra features above and beyond the basic characteristics of all objects.
Arrays, for example, have methods like .indexOf and .slice.
Those array methods are stored in another prototype called the Array prototype.
Since arrays behave a little differently from objects, the Array prototype even
has its own version of some of the standard methods like toString.
The Array prototype in turn delegates to the Object prototype so that
the non-unique parts of an array can be inherited from the Object prototype.
And not every single method will need to be
reimplemented here on the Array prototype.
Notice that the Array prototype and Object prototype both have
dot constructor properties even though one delegates to the other.
So what do you expect to happen when you query an array for
its dot constructor property?